thanks okay so um
especially under after uh spending a
couple years in
in san diego i've been obsessing
for quite a while uh about
the following two questions so one is
what is the connection opium let's see
let's try to
there we go what's the connection
between
fbt algorithms or parameterized
algorithms and
exact algorithms
this is let's say call it question one
so in particular can you use tools
and techniques from one field to improve
algorithms in the other
are there any very direct connections
where
you can take algorithms from one of them
and just directly apply them
in the other and the second question is
in exact algorithms why
are algorithms for satisfiability so
different from algorithms for basically
everything else
so basically if you look at the
algorithms for satisfiability and you
compare them
with let's say subset optimization
problems
and i'm going to say here other
subset optimization problems then the
algorithms look
pretty different and the reason i say
other subject optimization problems
is that satisfiability is
actually a subset optimization problem
so what do i mean
by a subset optimization problem here
your input say a graph or formula or
something like that
defines some hidden family
and what you want to do is to just find
one set
in the family so you have some universe
of size l so you have some input it
defines
some universe of some size m and
some family implicitly over the universe
and your goal is simply to find one set
in the family
where where you have oracle access to
the family being like
is this set in the family or not okay
so simple example c
sat i'm using neither k
sat nor dsat for reasons that
hopefully will become appearance during
the talk uh so this is
in so here of course inputs is a formula
i in c c and f so
all clauses have size of not c and the
question is
is there an assignment that satisfies
the formula
all right how is this a
subset problem well the universe is the
set of variables
right and the family contains of
all sets of variables such that setting
them to true and everyone else
to false satisfies the formula
easy enough all right another one would
be
c hitting set so here
input is a family
let's call it containing the sets
s1 s2
sm over some universe u
and you're asked and also an integer
k and you're asked does there exist
a subset of the universe of size at most
k
that intersects all of the sets in the
family
right and if this is c hitting sets then
all of the sets have size
at most c okay uh how is that
a subset problem well your solutions
or sets in the family are the sets
of size at most k that intersect
everyone
in the input family so so again there is
some
hidden implicit family that's implicitly
defined
by the input instance and you ask is
this family non-empty or not
that's all you're doing
okay so so so now that we have set the
stage and then like
ask the questions define subset problems
everything is
nice and clean so far let's look at
one already known very concrete
connection between fpt algorithms
and exact algorithms so in fpt
algorithms
one way so some a question that is often
asked is can i find a solution of size
at most k
right so i give you some i give you some
universe
uh and i can i find the set in this
implicit family of size at most
k and you want to measure your running
time now not in terms of n
but in terms of this k
fine so
in the parameterized version of c south
i would ask
find satisfying assignment
of weight
at most k so with at most k ones
all right
so what about the connection between fbt
and exact algorithms
so so this is this is well known i think
this is folklore
so if my problem is solvable
if this is a subset problem if it's
solvable in time
c to the k then
when i get an instance of size n
i can guess the size k of the solution
and for every value of k between 1
and n i can do whatever is fastest
out of running this algorithm and doing
brute force
so then my running time in
runtime in terms of n is at most
the maximum because k
is given to me by the devil of the
minimum of c to the k
and n choose k
and and notice that m choose k
is better than 2 to the m
as long as k is bounded away
from n over 2. so so if k is
is slightly less than n over two then
you're doing better than two to the m
and c to the k so so for
if if i look at k over two then then
four to the k over two that that's
that that's two to the m right but if c
is less than 4
then you're beating 2 to the m okay so
for c
less than 4 you can be 2 to the m
but this is somehow unsatisfactory right
i mean what about
algorithms that run in time 10 to the m
or algorithms that rather
tend to decay or algorithms that run in
time four to decay
can you get anything from them so one
example example of applying this
algorithm
is for the satisfiability problem
suppose i want to give you an algorithm
for threesat so all clauses have size at
most three
and i want to find a satisfying
assignment with at most k1s
there's a simple algorithm with running
time 3 to decay
right because you pick up a clause that
hasn't been satisfied yet
or you need to flip one of the variables
okay you guess guess which one of the
three variables to flip
so you branch in three ways and in each
of the directions you're going towards
your solution so so
after a depth k in your recursion tree
you would have reached your solution if
there was one
so so you can do this quite easily
by local search in time
3 to the k and then you ask yourself
okay well what does that give you here
well this gives you the stunning
algorithm for 3s out with running time
1.95 to the power n which of course is
much much worse than everything else
that's out there
okay so so hopefully i've convinced you
that okay this this connection exists
but it's rather unsatisfactory
so so so you really want to do something
better over here
so so now we digress or rather we end
with this digression and then talk about
the second question and this is why are
sat algorithms
so different from algorithms for other
problems
so what to do most so what do the
algorithms the best algorithms for
sat look like and what do the algorithms
for
the other problems look like um
for for sat
there are basically two prevalent
techniques
one is
picking a random solution
and then doing local search around that
and another one is
random decision
plus inference so what do i mean by that
you you pick a random variable you you
randomly set its value
you pick another random variable you
randomly set its value
and then if at any point you have some
variables so you know what their value
should be well you set them to that
okay so this is this is the random
decision plus inference paradigm
and then you have random sampling in
local search paradigm which i'm going to
talk about mostly so this
this is what i'm going to spend my time
time talking about
uh with respect to
like basically everything else
with of course quite a few notable
exception
the the paradigm people use
is branching so what do i mean by
branching you pick up some element in
your universe and you
spend a lot of effort figuring out how
to pick that element in a smart way
and then you decide either it goes into
your solution or it doesn't
and then you measure your running time
in terms of what happens and and somehow
for sat algorithms branching is is what
started out also
to be giving the best algorithms but
sort of quickly
people figured out how to do other
things whereas here
for for everything else the hitting set
for example branching is
still the champion
so before trying to understand how how
we can
transfer some of the techniques from
here
over here um
i want to talk a little bit about these
kind of algorithms because they're
pretty cool
so so i'll talk about an
algorithm of cherneg building on the
algorithm of papa de metrio
who gave an algorithm for for k sat
using the following two ideas so these
ideas are sort of
implicitly hidden inside of the paper
they're just below the surface and then
they were made explicit later by don
segetal but but the first one of these
ideas
is the following so for sat
if we can do local search
in time c to the power
let's say l
okay where c is some constant
then we can solve the problem
in time 2 minus
2 over c plus 1
to the power m okay so for example
if you could do local search i'll i'll
explain to you what i mean by local
search okay
if you can do local search in time two
to the l
then you can solve the problem in time
two minus two
over uh over
two yes so four-thirds which is exactly
what shortness of the running time of
sonic's algorithm is like 1.3333 to the
m
okay so
first what is local search what does
sonic's
algorithm do so the local search problem
is
quite simple so i give you as input the
formula phi
still in in ccnf and then it's
i mean i'm using the same constant for
for ccnf
and uh the running time and then that's
not really a coincidence
but uh okay so input is a formulaify
an assignment let's say call it sigma
and the question is the and an integer l
and the question is does there exists
a satisfying assignment
sigma prime such that the distance from
sigma
to sigma prime is at most l so so the
question is
if i give you an assignment that isn't
satisfying yet
can i flip at most l of the variables
from true to false or false to true
right and satisfy the formula
yes and i claim that
this problem does have
an easy c to the l algorithm
i've already told it to you right as
long as there is a clause
that isn't satisfied you guess
which one of the variables you should
flip and then you do that
so you branch into c ways
the depth of your recurrence is at most
l so you have c to the l leaves happy
happy
okay so what does this give you
well it gives you an algorithm with
running time
two minus two over
three plus one so four to the power n
right
okay so so so this is what shawnee does
number one and then what tronic does
number two
really cool idea is that you don't
really have to do the local search
problem
it is sufficient to do permissive local
search problems
okay so what is that so
so just as before input is
phi and sigma and
al your task now isn't to find
a satisfying assignment of distance at
most l
but your task is the following
if there exists a satisfying
assignment sigma prime
such that distance from
sigma to sigma prime is at most l
then output
some satisfying assignment
okay so if
there is a satisfying assignment in the
bowl you're looking for
then output some satisfying assignment
and what tronic showed was that
this guy can actually be done
in time two to the l right giving the
algorithm for sat with running time
one point three three four three sat
with running time one point three three
three for your favorite number of threes
okay all right
so how does this
reduction from
local search to solving actually work
what you do is based on the universe
size
n you pick some l so you pick an
l that is based solely
on the size of the universe
and the running time of your local
search algorithm but your local search
algorithm
isn't dependent on the input right so so
you fix the local search algorithm and
get based on the size of the input
you fix l then you pick a random
assignment
fine and then you run the permissive
local search algorithm
with that value of l as the parameter so
you have some success probability
of ending up close to your solution
and then it takes some time to actually
find that solution
and of course the the bigger l you pick
the better success probability you have
of being close
and the more time you take searching the
ball
and there is a clever way of picking l
so that you get this running time
okay so
what is exceptionally cool
about this reduction from local search
to solving well it has nothing to do
with sat
this reduction of peaking around them
picking around an assignment and doing
local search about it has nothing to do
with that whatsoever
so if you can do local search
for any subset problem
then in time c to the l then you can
also solve it in time two minus two over
c plus one to the m
yay okay now
what do we mean by local search for the
subset problem
let me
so input is some subset
x of your universe again integer l
and your question is does there exists
at
s of the universe such that
the size of s is at most l such that if
i take the
symmetric difference of s and x
then that is a solution
right so if i take i pick up at most k
elements of the universe if they were in
the solution i take them out if they
were not in the solution equal them
and then i asked can i get the solution
by doing that all right if i can do
local search in
in this time i can solve my problem in
that time
okay we showed that you can do this for
sat
now let's do it for the hitting set
okay so let's remember what is the
solution for the hitting set
so it is such that
so x is a
solution this means that
the size of x is at most k
and for all sets as i
in my input the intersection of s i and
x is not empty
all right so so we have a simple local
search algorithm for c
sats let's just use that for local
search
on on the hitting set okay
as long as there is a set that hasn't
gotten
an element yet some element has to be
put in
to your hitting set okay but let's do
that
fine everything is great you're still
branching at time c to the k
but everything
is a hitting set right picking the
entire universe is a hitting set
but it's too big it doesn't satisfy this
guy
and now the question is well how can i
start removing
elements from my solution
while keeping it a solution and how fast
can i do that
and you think about it and you think
about it and you don't find an efficient
solution
and the bad news is that you won't find
an efficient solution
because this problem for the hitting set
is actually w1 hard
okay so you you just won't be able to do
it even for d equal to
even for c equal to two so so this
for two hitting that this is
w1
big sound face okay so
what can we do about that well
where were we having trouble in our
local search
when we were when we had to add elements
to our solution we were doing great
when we had to remove elements from our
solution
we were in deep trouble so let's just
make
a local search where you can't remove
things
from your solution so in particular
let's do the
random sampling step of like the
randomized algorithm of shellnig where
you you pick some initial seed and you
do local search from it
but you make life easier for the local
search algorithm
by only being allowed to move upwards
at the cost of decreasing your success
probability in the first step
right so you might have to change the
size of the balls here you're looking in
okay so now we were going to define a
different problem
okay let's call this the extension
problem right so in
it's basically the same as this except
that you're only allowed to add elements
so
input is uh some set
x and some l and the question is
does there exist some set s now
that isn't in your set x such that the
size of s
is at most l and x union
s is a solution
right and now notice that for
d hitting that we do have
or c headings out has
a c to the l algorithm
for this problem right because we did
what i've told
you several times now as long as there
is a set that isn't happy yet
there are only three ways to make it
happen
okay so this works
what is our algorithm let me write it
down so
what do you see in this case what what
is c
in this case so if it's three hitting
that so hitting with sets of size three
then the local search algorithm is three
to the l if it is five hitting set it's
five to the l
okay
so what does the algorithm do
based on n
and k
pick some integer t less than or equal
to k
okay
sample a set x
from the universe
of size t
uniformly at random and now i want to do
local search upwards
for my set x and now i actually know
that if i picked t i know that i will
have to add
k minus t elements in order to get up to
my solution
yes so
do extension
from x with
l equals k minus t because
that is how many elements i can i should
add in order to get my solution
okay this is the algorithm
okay so
when do i succeed i succeed
if now i have a solution and when i
pick this set
that that set is actually a subset of my
solution
okay so
let's see
so so let's look at one round like one
round of this algorithm
what is its running time and what is its
success probability
so the the running time of this guy
well it's just c to the power
k minus t right sampling is polynomial
time
what is the success probability
well i have and choose
t ways to pick a set from the universe
and if i have a solution of size k
then there are k choose t ways
to pick a set of size t from the
universe
okay fantastic so my running time
now if i want to boost the success
probability to constant
i have to run it this many times right
one over successful
so for constant success probability my
running time is going to be
let's see let's do it here
let's see can can everyone see what i
write here
okay fine so my running time is going to
be
and choose oh let me put it a little bit
closer
and choose t over
characteristic times
c to the k minus t
yeah okay now
given k
we can compute this value for every t
right so we can pick t so that this is
minimized
so our rounding time is the minimum
over k less than or equal to t
t less than or equal to k
right because we have to sample a set
that's smaller than our solution
but the size of the solution
is of course given to us by the devil so
so this is the
max over k less than or equal to m
yes so this is the running time of our
algorithm
okay and after about two pages of high
school calculus
you can show that this is at most
two minus one over c to the power
so in particular
for three hitting that we
just gave an algorithm with running time
so three headings out
we just gave an algorithm with running
time one minus one
over three to the power and
1.666 for your favorite number of six
what two minus one over three two minus
one
what
there we go that that would be that
would be exceptional
i mean i heard graph isomorphism was a
quasi polynomial
yeah exactly
uh okay so um
all right so
here is another interesting thing let's
look at the extension problem
let's look at the extension problem for
the hitting set
so i give you some family and i give you
a set
initially that i have to start from i
have to extend my solution
by distance by adding at most l guys
okay
but notice that uh extending the
solution
in the hitting set instance quickly
reducing to
finding a solution of size at most l
because for every vertex and so for
every element that i know
is in my hitting set anyway all of the
sets that contain them are hit
so you just remove him and you remove
all of the sets that contain him
right so so the extension problem
prettily reduces
to the to solving right so extension
just reduces to
find solution of
size at most l well now let's call it k
right ah okay yeah
okay and and this is what parameters
algorithms
is all about right so
for three hit things that there is an
algorithm with running time so three
headings out
there is an algorithm with running time
two to the zero seven
something five five i think to the k
right so this immediately gives me a
better algorithm here
two minus one over two to the zero seven
five five and so on and this gives you
an algorithm
like something like 1 to the
53 to the m beating what is there
already k is maximized
yes
sorry i mean think of it like this
so does this make it easier
uh here okay
yes because because i i pick t
right and now i'm looking
so so think so so think about like this
i'm looking for a solution of size k
right and i need to try this if i'm
looking for a solution for size k i need
to try every possible value of k
unless k is given to me as input in the
case of d hit things out
k is actually given to me as input i'm
looking for a solution of size k
right then i'm going to pick a subset of
size t
uniformly at random and try to extend it
well if i have a subset of size t
and i'm trying to extend it to a set of
size k
i better add k minus t elements yeah
all right so so where were we uh we were
saying that
and and this reduction here holds for
for a bunch of problems but it holds for
most things you like so for most things
you like that are subset problems
c to the k algorithms immediately give
you two minus one over c to the n
algorithms yay
now we're happy now this this is much
cooler um
and and i won't really go into saying
how you prove this
but let me convince you that any c
to the k algorithm or like c to the
algorithm algorithm actually beats
2 to the m right in the previous
trade-off you needed something better
than four to decay
to beat two to the end now let me
convince you that anything
beats so any c to the k actually beats
two to the m
all right so uh
suppose i give you as
input and then k right so and i'm
looking for a solution of size k
then my running time is going to be and
choose k
if i pick and set and just try all
possibilities
okay here is here is a ridiculous
algorithm
for trying all sets of size k pick
a random set of size k and
see if it is a solution or not repeat
right
now the success probability of picking a
random set
random is 1
over n choose k right because if there
is one solution and you pick one at
random
that's the probability you pick it okay
um
now let's look at the different way of
formulating the exactly
the exact same thing
all right um when i
pick my first element
what's the probability that that is the
subset of the solution well
it's k over m so it's like one
over n choose k which happens to be
equal to
k over n then i pick another element
ah my probability is k minus one
and minus one i pick another element and
so on
and when i pick the teeth element my
probability
is n minus t by k minus t
and in the very end my probability is
k minus k minus 1 also known as one
divided by n minus
k minus one what
oh thank you all right i'm doing the
same thing right this is
here we go k minus t n minus d thank you
all right okay so um
this probability if you think of k as
being something like m half
this is quite good right this is
something like
about one half this probability is
pretty bad
right this is one over and half right
so this is something like one over n
right and so your factors
for success probability you have and
half of them and they get worse and
worse
as you progress right at some point
the success probability drops and
so so here this drops
below one to the c
right because it starts out as good and
then it ends up really bad at some point
it drops at one over c
and after that it only keeps getting
worse
right so if
now your success probability for these k
minus t uh remaining elements
yes is much worse than one over c to the
k
minus t so it is much smarter to instead
run
the extension algorithm in time c to the
k minus t
and this happens no matter what c is if
you if because one over
m is less than one over c for any c
yes
when you go to the one point five didn't
you apply
the same method on a smaller
inset problem like you
yes why can't you do it several times
um so what's happening is that you're
sampling
and when you're sampling your universe
reduces and
at the same time your solution reduces
uh and what is happening is that the
ratio
of the universe size to the solution
size changes so
after one application is the question
yes interesting
okay
okay yes
so so i think it's quite easy for from
this to convince oneself that yes
indeed for any c you get something
that's better than two to the m
right uh however how much better is not
obvious and well
you you'd differentiate this
do some maximum do some minimum and this
is what you end up with honestly i don't
understand why
all right um what comments should i make
well
well some nice examples of of
applications to this right
one we already saw we we got the best
algorithm
for for d hitting saturn right so
another application is uh let's look at
the interval deletion problems also
i want to delete as few vertices as
possible
to get an interval graph so
what uh interval a graph is an integral
graphic if you can
represent it as an intersection of
intervals yes
um okay so so
clearly you can do it in time two to the
n
this is naive then quite recently there
was some
hard work done by people in this room
among others
that that got it down to 2 minus epsilon
to the power
m for for epsilon being something like 1
over 10 to the power 20.
uh but at the same time there
is a recent published algorithm for
interval division with running time
h to the power k so so can i find the
solution of size
k and time 8 bar okay so what our
theorem does immediately 1.875 to the
power
quite noticeable bit right all right
let's look at another example let's look
at the
min once sat problem
so this is the variant of
the sat satisfiability problem where i
not only want to find the satisfying
assignment i want to find a satisfying
assignment
with the minimum number of ones in it
right so what are al so of course the
local search thing that we did
runs in time c to the k even for that
right and
now we're getting min 1 south in time 2
minus 1
over c to the power n so for 3's out
it's
again 1.6666 to the n
for satisfying assignments with the
minimum number of ones
so on in the savings in the exponents
this is order of magnitudes the same
as for normal case out right and as far
as i know
i mean i don't know how well studied
this problem actually is the
the best thing i know is the naive
algorithm that like picks a clause and
says either this guy is true or
this guy's false that guy is true and so
on this gives you savings one over
two to the c much much worse than
savings one over c
right so this is significant progress
okay uh another another problem before
before i move on with
more technical things is feedback vertex
app
so i give you
as input a graph g and an integer k
so feedback vertex out
so input is a graph g integer k
and the question is can i delete
at most k vertices such
that g becomes a cyclic
so this is for undirected graphs and
for a while it was even open whether
this problem
can be done better than time two to the
m
and then there was some good progress
when it went down from
from 2 to the m to something like 1.85
to the m
then to 1.75 to the n
down to 1.74 to the m down to 1.73 to
the m
right yes so a forest
so so i have a i have a graph g integer
k
undirected yes
all right okay so so this is the
progress that's been happening for for
this paper
for this problem however we're very
happy this has
a very cool algorithm running time 3 to
the k
so we get 1.6667
to the end yay okay and
uh there are a bunch of more examples
you can see that look at the paper
uh these are some of the ones i'm most
happy about
but before we conclude let me let me say
some more things
what we get out of it and also a little
bit about
the randomization okay
um
so
what is it we were really doing
we we had some hidden family of
solutions
right because we had some
hidden family and
our analysis was that if you can do
local search
like so if local search
in time c to the l then i can find
a solution in time 2 minus 1 over c
to the m right this is what we said okay
now how did that analysis look like we
picked up one set in the family and we
asked how much time will it take
to find that set right
so in particular if i
instead could say something like this
if for any set
x of size t
the number of
k minus t
extensions and the number of
ways to extend that set to a solution by
adding k minus t vertices
is at most c to the k minus t
then the number of solutions
is actually at most 2 minus 1 over c to
the m
right just the same argument i mean i'm
not i'm not going to repeat the argument
it is really the same one
you you have some random process where
you first pick a random subset
of size t and then out of all the
extensions pick one at random
and then you lower bound the probability
for every set in your family of that set
being the one you picked
yes okay and so and it ends up being
at most this many subs so
for example the
for three heating set what we actually
end up doing is minim
is enumerating extensions of my sets
that are minimal hitting sets
yes so for example this implies that
the number of
minimal three hitting sets
is at most 2 minus
or 1 3 to the power n so this is like
1.6667
to the n 7 to the m thank you
okay there we go um
okay so for example here here is an
here is some nice fact so in a
tournament this is this graph where
between every pair of vertices there is
an arc in one of the two directions
and the moon showed in 71 that the
number of
minimal feedback vertex sets in a
tournament or maximum
induced acyclic sub tournaments is
something like 1.71 to the power n
then then gaspers and nick later
improved this to 1.67
to the m and now our result just
immediately
gets it from 1.67 to 1.666
some some more sixes just in one shot i
think this is quite cool another thing
is that
this also applies to minimal satisfying
assignments
so this is a crazy thing right like
checking whether
a given assignment is a minimal
satisfying assignment so whether you can
take some
variables and swift flip them from true
to false
and still satisfy the formula this is np
complete
right but so so we can't actually
even enumerate all of them but we can
enumerate a superset of them and say
that the number of minimal
satisfying assignments is at most this
is quite nice uh
what else should i say
let's see how much time do i have i have
some
a few more minutes okay so um
this algorithm is sort of inherently
randomized right we picked
we picked a random subset and we tried
doing local search
up from it and you don't know anything
about your solution so how can you
randomize it well you do know
one thing about this about your solution
you know its size
right you know that this is a solution
of size k
so let's figure out how to use that
to de-randomize that because because we
actually can do that
so recall that
my
success probability was k
choose t over n choose t
and my running time was c to the k minus
t
okay so based on k
i'm picking a set a number t and i'm
sampling
sets of size t uniformly at random right
and i'm succeeding if i pick this up
that was subset of my solution
and i have to repeat my trial inverse of
this many times
okay what if i constructed
the following thing
so what if i construct a family
f containing sets x1
x2 xr
so all of my xi's have the same size t
and they have the following property
that
for any set s
such that the size of s is equal to k
there is some guy in my family who is a
subset of them
yes so there exists x i
in the family such that x i is a subset
of s then if i had a good construction
of such a family
then instead of picking things at random
i could just run the local search from
every set
in the family and my running time would
be the size of the family
time c to the k minus t and we do
construct
a family of size
exactly this of course with some
sub-exponential overhead but
that doesn't really matter
okay uh and the cool thing is that this
also gives us
a deterministic algorithm to enumerate
all of the objects that we could count
the number of but this is exponential
space because you need
to keep track of who you have already
output and
remove duplicates if you care about not
having duplicates
yeah i won't say much about the
randomization so
let me conclude with a little bit of
philosophical remarks
all right so um
theta so so c to the k was enough to
beat
uh to beat two to the m right because it
eventually beats entries k
so in particular uh
also if i do something slightly better
than n choose k
at the cost of any c to the k that still
bits enters k so so
so like c to the k times n
choose k to the power
0.99
does eventually beat and choose k
when k is small enough compared to m
and i think this gives hope for for
using
this sort of approach for problems that
don't have single exponential time
algorithms for example
directed feedback vertex set right has
an fpt algorithm with running time k to
the k so for
k being something like n over log n that
algorithm is faster than brute force
right but if you could make that
algorithm run
in time 100 to the k
times square root of entries k right
then you would actually could use that
to be 2 to the m
i mean there is already an algorithm
better than two to the m
it runs in 1.9977 to the unpiped by
rasgun
but i have some hopes that maybe
something like this could actually beat
it
okay without having to get a single
exponential algorithm for dfes because
that's a major open problem
another thing is that some people
here are interested in algorithms with
even with running time
2 to the m minus one over g
of n so when you have savings that
depend on
your input size right and notice that
our approach basically gives you savings
like that
starting from any fpt algorithm of
course depending on your dependence on k
this becomes worse and worse it would be
interesting
and and because these things sometimes
are useful for proving
circuit lower bounds i would be very
happy to see someone prove a circuit
lower bound starting from an fpt
algorithm
let's see
so so what we are doing right now is we
really have a two-step process you you
pick a random set
and then you're on the local search
algorithm right picking a random set is
sort of uh
i mean it's it's also a branching
process right you just pick around the
vertex so pick another
vertex and so on and many of these
glucose algorithms are also branching
algorithms
and it makes sense that somehow if if
you interleave the
random picking and the local search
steps you might be able to get something
better
so so in fact with some tinkering here
and there
for many of the problems we consider we
could get something better
but it required a lot of tinkering and
we only got like fifth decimal
improvements
so so right i think so in particular for
example for
the number of tournament feedback vertex
sets
uh 1.6667 to the n is not the answer
the answer is smaller than that but the
gap between what we got and this
is so small that it's not even worth
mentioning
uh yep so one last one is
well we we used monotone local search
to get exact algorithms i just wonder
whether there are any interesting
exact algorithms problems for whom the
normal local search problem is easy
other other than just this viability
would be fun to get some
good exact algorithms based on that as
well
okay thanks
so so an interesting thing i mean okay
our approach doesn't do anything i mean
okay so so our approach does the
following if you can do
ksat in time n2 i mean okay if you can
do c
sat and find the solution of size k
better than
n choose k uh for
any linear so so basically instead of
looking at
i mean instead of beating 2 to the m you
can beat n choose k when you're looking
for small solutions
but we still don't know how to do that
then like the pessimistic view would be
that you can't do that other strong at
the edge
i was wondering for this deorization can
you use this
zero comma the website at universal sets
uh no so it's it's i mean the
construction
has some similarities but it uh it is
not the same
i i getting any new lower bounds like
brewing hardness w hardness with some
problem that from this construction
that was not known before uh we haven't
looked into it
this is a philosophical question that
your works
seem to obsolete previous hard work on
improving exercise
so so where all those ideas
go so are they useless or
misguided or weird or maybe if those
ideas are
reintroduced on your on top of your
technique then something can be improved
so so this is what i said basically i
mean uh
if those so typically if you reintroduce
those ideas on top of our technique
and did some thinking then you could get
really really tiny improvements
but i think that is mostly because we
haven't figured out the right way of
combining existing things with our thing
yet
and i think this is a very good question
the question goes back to a conversation
we had in corsica a while back and the
question is
see this runs on you have a k and you're
running it up through n you're
better to do the fpt for a while and
then eventually you're
it's better to do and choose k do we
know any examples where
in some intermediate range like you
basically have two phases
and you're worrying about when to move
the boundary do we know any
examples where where as k runs up
through n
you have three different phases
you know what i mean the different three
different algorithms
so if the running time of the local
search algorithm
doesn't only depend on the number of
things you're adding
but also the num the size of the set you
sample it has to depend on it in a very
good way
for for this to happen then i think
pretty much that is what happens but i'm
not sure like we did some analysis on
that
but i mean okay now i'm just guessing
so what is the title of the paper here
fast exact algorithms based on monotone
local search
uh it will eventually make its way on to
auto archive
oh it's not it's not
thanks again